foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
joining us on behalf of Wells Fargo's
big game food report which he'll explain
to us as we bring Debo in the 49ers wide
receiver the Niners went 13-4 this year
losing to the Eagles in the NFC title
game and we say hello to Debo Samuel
him here he comes okay all right
Marvin Marvin giving it Marvin given a
standing ovation
okay all right come on now you already
know Niner come on niners that's right
Mark come on Marv is a big big Niner fan
here I forgot all about that come on
let's go Debo's here come on he's giving
the ball anywhere in space let's go I'm
ready yeah we're thinking that maybe you
change your designation to wide receiver
and running back so you're like show hey
uttani the pitcher and hitter so you get
two contracts there now I know you got
your new contract but next time around
what if we do wide receiver running back
like WRB that thing I love that too
[Music]
can you play quarterback a little bit
yeah I can throw it a little bit but I
was wondering you know they could have
had you and McCaffrey playing
quarterback couldn't you guys switch
down or are you a better quarterback
than Christian in that game against the
Eagles
um oh no Heathrow passes he's been here
for it too I got through one so we both
won for once I mean uh really no matter
which one of us get back there in that
moment but
run on the sidelines there when you
realize that you may not have a
quarterback I mean it was tough
um with neither one of us being able to
uh call plays before and we see
Christian McCaffrey coming to huddle
with a with a quarterback wristband we
like hard
we're like all right we're in trouble
now if that's the case and you hear him
calling and playing he's like screaming
at the top of his lungs and we like bro
like you don't have to be there
but does he yell because the crowd is so
loud or does he think that's what you're
supposed to do he just thinks that's
what he's supposed to do and when he was
in a huddle like yo you can you can tone
it down a little bit
uh but you guys battled though I mean
it's a tough situation but you know at
what point do you realize we're in
trouble
um
we went and more so big trouble when
Purdy went down uh second play of the
game uh it got really really bad the
third play of the third player of the
second half when Josh went down we was
like yeah like
I don't know what's about to happen but
we're about to try everything possible
for like to try to get a win but as it
as it went on they knew we couldn't
throw the ball so like they just loaded
the Box up and just you know it didn't
end too well how good is that eagle team
um
I really can't tell you how good they is
because we didn't really have a fair
chance out there so I mean
um we had a great game plan we know
who's gonna attack we knew what we was
going to attack but we wasn't able to do
it what were you going to attack
um
the DBS you know all game long uh we was
going to go at them all all day long we
know
um they was they was quick to trigger on
certain stuff that they see on film so
we we had some stuffed out of whether we
knew they was going to bite it up and as
you can see um early in the game they'll
play pretty got sacked on Brandon are
you wide open yeah so were you talking
about they would they would jump the
routes a lot of times yeah they'll see
the they see the stem of a route and
just try to guess it and we had stuff in
the bag that was going to mess their
head up we didn't they was gonna have to
play unders all game long
well you know now I'm looking forward to
the do-over next year
but who's your quarterback
I mean um that's out of my control well
no you gotta vote
no vote no vote
you're going to the water under the
water early there no vote
how about Christian McCaffrey will be
your quarterback next year
uh it what hurts on you now after the
season's over
um honestly I'm not even that beat up
right now I feel feel pretty good you
know um during the game you know you
have some Nicks here and there but once
it's over like it just takes a couple
days just to get get back going and get
ready for practice but we wasn't getting
ready for practice I mean we had a
number of time now so um my body's doing
pretty good but do you hide injuries are
you good at hiding injuries oh no if I'm
hurting I'm gonna let cow know I'm
hurting I'm not going I'm not gonna go
out go out to practice and try to hurt
myself anymore
the best defense you win against this
year San Francisco 49ers training camp
going to the water again
[Laughter]
who's the guy that plays like he's all
out in practice on the Niners defense
Brad Warner every day oh man
every day like I could not be like a
scout team running back for our team
he's going to hit you and hurt you and
then when he get the hit and then all
them boys so it should be long days for
them boys out there man are they allowed
to hit you no I mean in training camp oh
they can hit you yeah you can hit
anybody in the train again you can't hit
the quarter we're not going to you're
not going to the ground though it's like
a thug oh okay
Fred Fred's underrated
ah oh no I'm talking Nationwide I think
with people watching the world knows but
they don't they don't they don't talk
about it this much but there's not too
many people like the Niners you know why
I don't know
well what's wrong with you ain't nothing
wrong with me I'm good yeah but but but
who do they not like uh they don't like
you know I'm saying the the hard ball
Smash Mouth team that we playing in that
third this year after every team played
as it was 117 to 116 so it kind of you
know
yeah but we respect that I mean are you
talking about players in the league hate
the Niners players we're not talking
about you yeah hell with those guys who
cares about them yeah who talked the
most when you play against them
um
I mean a lot of guys like they'd be
trying to be friendly with I mean
friendly they'd be trying to be friendly
with our receiver group because they
know you know we we block hard we play
physical and you know so what do they
say to Devo Samuel during a game oh not
too much nothing no but they're trying
to be nice to you yeah hey man good job
um best offense you saw this year
besides the 49ers best offense you saw
I mean
Chief's office is pretty pretty good
yeah yeah
my home's pretty good yeah of course
yeah
best quarterback in the NFL is who rob
Purdy
um
as bad as I want the Eagles to lose
um I got so much love for AJ Brown like
that's my dog so
um
dude that's losing you know um I want
him to win that's the only reason why
one day he goes to win because like you
know I have so much love and respect for
how he carry yourself how you play the
game and just the relationship he's
built before we even got drafted if I
put all the receivers top end receivers
lined you up 100 meter dash
who wins that
um
it's every kill wins yeah yeah like he's
different than everybody else he can run
okay but but what's that like for
somebody like you who can run and then
you see somebody who can run nah he
really like he really got gas he really
moving like we played we played we
played Miami him and him in the water
like you just see them boys like like
the touchdown that they scored the first
player of the game he run his receiver
down and he's 20 yards behind just
having fun just like well I tried to I
tried to hook up a race with Usain Bolt
and Tyreek Hill last year
I like you saying yeah well if I said
like a 40-yard dash or even 60 Tyreke I
think could take him in a 60 60 meters
you get those long legs going in 100
meters Usain Bolt gonna beat anybody on
well I mean what's that like you think
to be the fastest guy on the planet
billions of people there walking around
would you rather be that or the
heavyweight champ of the world
uh I'd rather be the heavy heavyweight
champ of the world okay
cause that used to be a big deal now I
don't know who the heavyweight is Tyson
Fury the heavyweight champion of the
world by the way did you uh watch LeBron
last night were you interested in that
um I was on the plane okay did you care
that he was passing Kareem on the
all-time scoring list I mean I'm a
LeBron fan so you know uh
I was I was enjoying it seeing it all
over Twitter and internet once I landed
um got off my flight have you met LeBron
I have not oh somebody's gonna hook you
up there come on wear your jersey and go
Courtside with them
I think he's a Cowboy fan isn't he hey I
don't know nothing about that yeah I
think he is but I know he's not a Niner
fan hey man not too many of them uh
Marvin is a Niner fan so Marvin asked if
he could uh ask you a question so you
got one question to ask Marv
all right so what's it like all right
you put me on the spot I'm I'm crazy you
want to go you want to go get a drink of
water like Debo does oh I don't have any
water all right now to drink right now
okay go ahead I just want to say I was a
big fan that was it I want no questions
no question no no nothing I just love
his game I just love how he goes about
it because the thing is back then oh
wide receivers nah he going after it you
give him the ball in space it's like pop
warner I would say you like a pop warner
Pop Warner the best player is just
giving the ball anywhere which I called
uh what y'all called like a killer man
with a football
so that's backyard where guys got the
ball and everybody's South Carolina
where you're you're the baddest man yeah
okay did you always win that no it was
it was actually a lot of good people out
there I mean and then you tackling with
no pads and stuff on but it was fun at
the time but as you look back you're
like nah what was we doing no oh now you
got a question
how many people say something like my
Grandmama give me that chain how many
Debo references from the movie Friday do
you get
I mean too many literally
who calls you by your full name uh my
stepmom oh are you in trouble when she
calls you there nah she just don't like
the name Devo oh okay
um do you want to uh explain what you're
doing with Wells Fargo the uh big game
food report here oh yeah 100
um here's what Hills well here with
Wells Fargo uh the Acura food report is
in
um prices are low um be sure to check
out Wells Fargo
um blog for food
uh let's see big game food report uh
Wells Fargo big game food report check
it out at Wells Fargo Food For Thought
blog to learn more what Marvin
I was just watching you work oh okay no
it's all good it's me you and Debo we're
hanging out what about everybody else
who
but I got a Broncos fan a Patriots fan
and I got a Bears fan yeah so they don't
have any questions they got nothing to
say this year yeah no it's good to see
you and uh thanks for stopping by good
luck with uh whatever happens uh started
next season the quarterbacking position
at least you have a couple of options
there with with Trey and Brock could be
worse and no Tom Brady did you think
that there was a chance Tom Brady was
coming to town
um I don't know you know uh
we let all the things handle yourself
yeah but when you heard that possibility
you heard a lot you know yeah
would that have been something
interesting oh no we would have had to
see
yeah all right take another drink of
water
he's Debo Samuel the 49ers we'll take a
break we're back after this in The Dan
Patrick Show